Chicago voters made history by electing
the city's first black female mayor Lori
Lightfoot won a landslide victory last
night over Tony prickling goal taking
about forty 74 percent of the vote
Lightfoot carried all 50 Chicago
election districts in the runoff Adriana
Diaz is outside City Hall in Chicago
with details of the anti-establishment
candidates win
Adriana good morning good morning
Lightfoot's victory marks another
milestone astilbe the first openly gay
mayor in Chicago history now she and her
opponent Tony Pratt Winkle who's also a
black woman both consider themselves
progressives but practical is a longtime
local official whereas Lightfoot is a
former prosecutor who's never held
public office and that was part of her
appeal it was a historic moment in
Chicago politics incoming mayor Lori
Lightfoot made her triumphant entrance
on stage alongside her wife and young
daughter you did more than make history
you created a movement for change right
foot was an unlikely outsider who
promised to break what she calls Chicago
cycle of corruption together we can and
will finally put the interest of our
people all of our people I had of the
interest of a powerful few in her
concession speech Toni prec Wankel vowed
to work with the new mayor elect the
work we've done the values we fought for
that doesn't end tonight
Lightfoot is inheriting a long list of
challenges
Chicago faces an estimated 250 million
dollar budget deficit next year and
billions that unfunded pensions with no
clear plan of how to fix it during the
campaign
Lightfoot made police reform a major
focus following outrage over the deadly
shooting of black teenager laQuan
McDonald by a white police officer we
can and we will build trust between our
people and our brave police officers so
that the communities and police trust
each other not theory
lightfoot is she will be the second
female mayor in Chicago history she'll
also join seven other black women
currently serving as mayors of major US
cities including Atlanta and New Orleans
Lightfoot takes office may 20th Nora
yeah the papers say Lightfoot in a
landslide and proof that the world is
changing you know it is changing there
lots of organizations that say now young
queer people young black women can see
that they can hold major political
office you don't have to have spent your
life in prison today and no experience
that's what's best yeah I mean she was a
former prosecutor but wasn't like
someone who has spent her whole life in
polliver held in the office